[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER HEIDEN: OK.
So welcome back,
everybody, to 705.
I know this has been a really
challenging semester for all
of us.
I want to particularly
acknowledge for the seniors
out there the tragedy of missing
the end of your senior year.
Hopefully us, MIT can
somehow make it up to you.
I can say for my part,
we will do our best
to teach you
biochemistry remotely.
And just as a couple
logistics, a reminder,
I'm Matt Vander Heiden.
I'm going to be covering
the remaining part of 705.
For the rest of the
semester, we get
to focus on biochemistry
of metabolism.
We're going to learn
what metabolism
is, why it's important.
And basically, this can be
quite a polarizing topic.
In my experience, people
tend to really love
or really hate metabolism.
It's interesting, because there
are some people out there who
pretend to hate it, but actually
deep down really love it.
Hopefully I will inspire you
over the rest of the semester
to at least have some
appreciation for why metabolism
is important.
And regardless, for those of you
who want to go to med school,
this is a favorite
topic of MCAT Exams.
And also you will see
that it will come up
in many different areas
of biology, regardless
of whether you go to
med school or not.
So if you do anything
further in biology,
hopefully you'll find this
material somewhat useful.
OK, so getting into
what metabolism is.
So I think it's good to
start with a textbook
definition of metabolism.
And so metabolism is
the chemical reactions
that all cells and organisms
use to do two things.
One, extract energy
from the environment.
And two, synthesize
the macromolecules
that make up all life.
So really, what
metabolism is then
is the chemistry that
makes life possible.
And so understanding
metabolism is really
something that will help you
better understand your food.
There's lots of
material out there
in the popular press about
what's healthy and what's not.
At least this will allow you to
form some of your own opinions
about those claims, and
how they relate to what
really goes on in
our cells and bodies.
There's lots of
implications for medicine,
very relevant to agriculture,
the energy sector,
biofuels come from.
And so metabolism
really matters to tackle
many of the challenges
that face us in society.
Now as a topic, this
can be very daunting.
As shown here on this
image, we have hundreds,
this is a typical
metabolic pathway chart
that is hanging in the
walls of my office,
many other laboratories
and academic places
around the world.
If you look at this chart,
it's filled with hundreds
of enzymes, complex pathways.
Our goal here is not
to memorize this chart.
You can always look up details
of any pathway or reaction
that you want.
The goal here really is to
see beyond this complexity.
I want you to appreciate
why metabolism
works the way it does, why this
chart is organized as it is.
Because what we will find
is that this chart is really
variations on relatively
few reactions.
It basically is life
repurposing similar chemistry
to do many different things.
I think there is a
beauty in how life
can use these
reactions to get such
a diversity of
macromolecules, and enable
cells to solve all kinds
of different problems.
You will see that
all of the pathways
really follow common principles.
These are shared across all
species and all forms of life.
And so at the chemical level,
all life is really related.
And this is why it's so
relevant to understanding
many of the challenges in
medicine, understanding
ecology, evolution.
And for you MIT
students, you'll see
it's also very critical for
using engineering approaches
based on biology to solve
various problems in the world.
OK.
So now let's start getting
into this a bit more.
Now, the first topic that
we're going to cover over
the next several
lectures really relates
to coming back to sugars
and carbohydrates, which
I talked about and introduced
in my previous lecture.
And we're going to do
this because sugars
and carbohydrates are key
energy transduction molecules
and cells.
And it really facilitates a
discussion of the principles
for how metabolism works.
Now our goal here isn't
to memorize pathways.
We could read about the
glycolytic pathway in an hour.
I could draw it up here in
a very short period of time.
Many of you have
probably already done
this in high school.
Our goal is instead to
understand this pathway
at a deeper level, really see
why the breakdown of sugars
works the way it does, how cells
use this to release energy,
and how that can be used to
support other cell functions.
And so before we
get to that, I want
to start by introducing just
a couple high-level concepts
about metabolism.
And so really, based on
our definition before,
metabolism is really
about two things.
It's about making stuff, and
we have a fancy term for that.
That is called anabolism.
And it's about
breaking stuff down.
And the term for that
is called catabolism.
And anabolism, building
stuff-- that is,
producing biomass, growing
all of the material
that's out there, anabolic
steroids help you grow.
This is anabolism
to build stuff.
That is one side of metabolism.
The other side is breaking
stuff down, catabolism.
That is, breaking down
our food, eating food.
Digesting our food is
a way to get energy.
Now of course, to reproduce,
life has to build more cells.
You need more stuff.
You can't create
something from nothing,
and so that requires
energy input.
Anabolism typically
requires energy input.
Whereas that energy has
to come from somewhere.
And that's where
catabolism comes from.
We have to break down food.
And ultimately,
catabolism is the source
for biological energy for
many different systems.
Now, some of this is
actually somewhat intuitive.
We all learned as
little kids that we
need to eat food if we're
going to grow up and be
big and strong.
You also know that if
you're going to run a race,
you've got to eat
a bunch of food,
you need that energy
to fuel your activity.
But maybe what's less
intuitive to many of you
is we also need energy
to sustain life,
even if we're doing
absolutely nothing.
OK, adults, sit on
the couch all day,
hopefully they're not growing.
But they'll still starve if they
don't constantly eat some food,
even if they're inactive.
And so why is that the case?
Well, hopefully some of
you recall the second law
of thermodynamics.
So what is the second
law of thermodynamics?
It's, in effect, the entropy
of the universe is increasing.
That the universe continually
tends towards disorder.
Life is exactly the
opposite of this.
Life is actually
maintaining extreme order
in the face of the second law.
And so all life must
constantly battle entropy.
And many have described life
at the very highest level
as being really the
ability to maintain order,
to fight entropy, which of
course requires constant energy
input.
And metabolism is the process
that all cells use to do this.
Now for humans, I
think we all know
we need to eat and breathe
in order to stay alive.
For you future MDs
out there, what
happens if your heart stops,
or you stop breathing?
Well, of course, you die in
a matter of several minutes.
Why is that?
Well, that's because
every cell in your body
has to do constant catabolism
in order to derive energy,
in order to remain viable.
This means they need constant
food, and particularly
oxygen delivery.
And if you don't
get those things,
metabolism can no longer
work, and the cells die.
And so energy is sort
of this mystical concept
that we like to talk about.
And so before we delve
a little bit deeper
into what I mean by
biological energy, what it is,
why we have to constantly do
catabolism to maintain it,
I want to go back and say
just a little bit more
about carbohydrates and finish
our discussion there, and talk
about carbohydrates and sugar
polymers, polysaccharides,
because this has some
additional properties
I didn't have time to cover
in my prior lecture that
is important to
understand how it
allows these molecules to store
energy in a very efficient way.
And it will also enable us to
talk a little bit about how
carbohydrates can also be
used as structural molecules
for lots of different organisms.
All right, so a little diversion
to discuss carbohydrates
and polysaccharides.
And so if you recall
from my prior lecture,
sugars that are greater
than four to five carbons
can exist either in open
chain or ring forms, furanose
or pyranose rings.
I'll just remind you by
redrawing up here, glucose.
So this is D glucose, drawn
in the open chain form.
Remember this can form a ring.
OK.
So it's a reminder,
carbon 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
If we have this hydroxyl
group from carbon 5,
form a hemiacetal bond with
the aldehyde at carbon 1,
you get this ring structure.
This would be alpha
or beta, depending
on whether the hydroxyl
group here at carbon 1
is pointing up or pointing down.
D-glucopyranose.
So this is review of what we
already talked about last time.
Now, what I want
to talk about is
that if we form a disaccharide
or a polysaccharide-- that is,
begin to make sugar
bonds, and if we
do that in a way that ties up
this hemiacetal or hemiketal
bond, this then
prevents the ring
from opening and gaining
access to that carbonyl,
that aldehyde carbonyl, as this
moves between the open chain
and the ring form.
And so a good example of this
is the disaccharide sucrose.
So sucrose is a disaccharide
of glucose plus galactose.
And here is what this
disaccharide looks like.
OK, so you have here, glucose
in the alpha-D-pyranose form.
Here's fructose in the
beta, because the OH group
is pointing out.
Fructofuranose form.
And so the formal name for
this molecule, sucrose,
would be
alpha-D-glucopyranosyl 1-2,
because we're going from carbon
1 of glucose to carbon 2,
there's 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6 of fructose.
Beta-D-fructofuranose.
Sucrose or
alpha-D-glucopyranosyl
1-2 beta-D-fructofuranose.
OK, so this disaccharide
forms a bond
between carbon 1 and carbon 2.
That would be the
aldehyde in glucose,
or the ketone tied
up in the hemiacetal
or the hemiketal bond
of these two molecules.
And so there's no way that
either of these sugars
can access the open chain
form, without breaking
this O-glycosidic bond.
And that's one reason why
sucrose is a very good storage
molecule for carbohydrates,
because without breaking
that bond, you prevent access
to gaining these reactive
aldehyde or ketone
bonds, that could
react with some other
molecule in the cell.
Now, I mention this
because whether or not
a particular sugar is
enabled to get access
to this reactive aldehyde
or ketone really forms
the basis for a classic
sugar detection lab test.
And this is relevant to discuss
this lab test because it
explains some nomenclature
that is still used,
and in fact, we
will continue to use
a bit as we discuss some
aspects of sugar metabolism.
So what this test
is, is basically,
is that if you heat the sugar
with copper, which is blue,
and that copper can gain access
to a free carbonyl--that is,
if the sugar can access the
open chain form to expose
the aldehyde or a ketone, that
copper can then become reduced
to copper plus.
That changes the color
from blue to red.
And so if you reduce the copper,
you oxidize the bond there.
And this test turns positive
if there is a reducing sugar,
is what it's called.
So a sugar that reduces the
copper from the blue 2 plus
state to the red plus
state is a positive test.
And so basically,
a reducing sugar
is any sugar with an ability
to access an open chain form.
Because that will
provide the free aldehyde
or ketone to reduce the
copper in this test.
So this term, reducing
sugar, obviously applies
to all monosaccharides, because
every single one of them
has an aldehyde or a ketone, and
can access the open chain form.
But it will only apply
to some disaccharides
or polysaccharides.
So let's come back
to sucrose up there.
So is sucrose a reducing sugar?
No, it's not, because
there is no way
that you can access a
free aldehyde or a ketone
in sucrose, because it's
tied up in that O-glycosidic
bond between carbon 1 of glucose
and carbon 2 of fructose.
And so you need
to break that bond
to give them monosaccharide
subunits in order
to access the open chain form.
However, let's give an
example of a disaccharide
that is a reducing sugar.
And that's the
disaccharide maltose.
So maltose is basically
two glucose molecules.
And those two glucose
molecules are like this.
So this has a O-glycosidic
bond between carbon 1
of this glucose, and
carbon 4 of that glucose.
And so formally, this would
be alpha-D-glucopyranosyl 1-4
alpha or beta.
If it's pointing down, it's
alpha, pointing up, it's beta.
D-glucopyranose.
So maltose or
alpha-D-glucopyranosyl 1-4
alpha or beta D-glucopyranose
is a reducing sugar,
because this sugar could
access the open chain form.
You could open up this carbonyl
and expose the free aldehyde
at position 1.
Now, we could also
refer to this sugar
as having two different ends.
We can refer to this end as
being the non-reducing end,
and this end as being
the reducing end.
Because of course, this
bond, this aldehyde
on the first glucose is tied
up in this O-glycosidic bond,
whereas the one on
this one is not.
So this end is non-reducing,
and this end is reducing.
Now this becomes
much more relevant
if we start talking
about polymers.
And so what starch is.
So starch, what potatoes
are made out of,
is basically a
polymer of maltose.
Polymer of maltose molecules.
So basically our glucose
with 1-4 linkages.
OK, so I could draw that
end, the reducing end
of the polymer, in
the alpha or beta.
But this here, being
the non-reducing end.
Every other subunit is tied up
in this 1-4 O-glycosidic bond.
And so starch is
really a polymer
of glucose molecules
with bonds between the 1
and the 4 position
of each subunit.
Now we will see
later that we build
and break down starch
polymers from only one end,
from the non-reducing end.
And so having these terms,
reducing and non-reducing,
provides the term to specify
different ends of a polymer.
Reducing and non-reducing
ends turns out
to also be important for naming
conventions for disaccharides
or polysaccharides.
And this becomes
relevant if we consider
the disaccharide lactose.
So lactose is also a polymer
of glucose plus galactose,
except this polymer of glucose
plus galactose, unlike sucrose,
is different because it
has a different linkage
between the sucrose is a
disaccharide of glucose
plus fructose.
Fructose, I wrote
the name correctly.
But lactose is a disaccharide
between glucose and galactose.
And so I'll draw it here.
OK, so this is lactose.
This is galactose here
on the non-reducing end.
So the formal name for
this would be beta,
because there's a
beta linkage here
between carbon 1
of this galactose
and carbon 4 of this glucose.
So be
beta-D-galactopyranosyl 1-4.
And this is glucose
in the alpha or beta.
D-glucopyranose.
Lactose, or
beta-D-galactopyranosyl 1-4,
alpha or beta, depending if
I drew down, alpha, up, beta.
D-glucopyranose.
Now, this also has
non-reducing and reducing ends.
And by convention, you
would name the sugar
from the non-reducing
end to the reducing end.
Hence I put galactopyranosyl
1-4 alpha-D-glucopyranose,
named them in that order.
Now you'll note that lactose,
unlike starch, unlike maltose,
unlike sucrose, links
these disaccharides
with a beta linkage between
this sugar and that sugar,
where the other ones
had alpha linkages.
And structurally, this
is very different.
And I just want
to point that out.
So this here is basically
alpha-D-glucopyranose.
And so alpha, this is carbon 1.
This is the hydroxyl
pointing down.
That's why it's alpha.
If I make an O-glycosidic
bond to another sugar,
you can see that it points and
creates this kinked structure.
Now, if I were to
make this beta,
this hydroxyl rather
than being here
would be at this
position on carbon 1.
You can see that
that now creates
a very different geometry.
Now you have a flat molecule,
as opposed to a kinked molecule.
Now, this has
consequences, of course,
for the enzymes that
break down the sugars.
Obviously, it's going to be
a very different enzyme that
breaks a bond in
this orientation,
versus a bond in
that orientation.
This has, basically implications
for what enzymes we have.
And so lactose, of
course, is milk sugar.
All mammals make
milk, so make lactose,
and break it down
when we're babies.
But most mammals tend
to lose expression
of the enzyme lactase that's
able to break this 1-4 beta
linkage as we age.
And this is basically
what accounts
for lactose intolerance.
Now, if you think about it, in
the world, much of the world
has issues with varying
degrees of lactose intolerance
in adulthood.
The exception to this is often
people of European ancestry.
Why is this?
Well, Europeans historically
drank milk well into adulthood.
And so this selected
for continuous lactase,
the enzyme that wouldn't
break that beta 1-4 linkage.
The expression as people
move into adulthood.
And so it's an example of how
cultural things, drinking milk
into adulthood, really
affected evolution,
such that that
subpopulation of people,
people with that genetics to
increase lactase expression,
don't become lactose
intolerant as they age.
Now, this alpha
versus beta linkage--
that is, whether or not you have
this more kinked versus more
flat structure-- also
has a major effect
on the structure of
a polymer as well.
And so if we look here
at this starch polymer,
it's basically this series
of glucose molecules
stuck together with
alpha 1-4 linkages.
So that's going to create
a kinked structure.
This is best shown
here on this slide.
So you can see this
kinked structure.
And so when you
build this polymer,
you're going to end up more with
this helical structure in 3D
space.
That's a very efficient way
to store glucose monomers
in much less space than
you would otherwise
get with beta linkages.
Now, it turns out that nature
takes this a step further.
And in addition to just
having this starch polymer,
it turns out sometimes
you can add branches
to the starch polymer
to further increase
the efficiency of
energy storage.
So if you have here
a starch polymer,
so let me just draw
here a couple subunits.
So this here is a starch
polymer, glucose polymer
with alpha 1-4
linkages that I can
put an additional branch on
this by adding on a linkage
up here on the top.
With an alpha 1-6 linkage.
So the 1 position of here,
to the 6 position of here,
which has the effect of creating
branches on this long polymer,
such that you have a
single reducing end,
and lots of non-reducing ends.
Each of these non-reducing
ends has a polymer
of alpha 1-4 linkages
that would be
stuck to the main chain polymer
via this alpha 1-6 linkage.
And this has a couple
implications for storage.
The first is, by only
having one reducing end,
it reduces maximally the
exposure to a free aldehyde.
And so that makes it
a good storage sugar.
And also as we will
see, we're going
to break down these sugar
polymers biologically
from the non-reducing ends,
and build from those ends.
And so there's lots
of hooks or lots
of places to either add
or remove sugars from,
which allows you to
access carbohydrates
quickly as needed.
That's shown nicely
here on this slide,
better than I can draw it.
So up here, you have
your non-reducing end
across the polymer.
So this here would be starch
with the alpha 1-4 linkages
on the polymer, or
reducing end on one side,
non-reducing end on the other.
You can then add
branch points to that
by making an O-glycosidic
bond between carbon 1
down to carbon 6,
creating a branch.
And so you can see this
helical branch structure
will then form.
That is both very efficient
to pack lots of glucose
into one place, and give
lots of non-reducing ends
with which to build
and remove sugars
from for biology to either
store or quickly access
sugar molecules as needed.
Now, in plants, of
course, potatoes
use starch in a straight chain.
We know that.
However, plants also use
this branched structure.
This is a molecule
called amylopectin.
Amylopectin is better known in
the food industry as Sure-Jell.
It's the material that
allows you to make jelly.
It's the jelling agent in jelly.
And effectively, this
has every 24 to 30 units.
There would be a branch with
one of these alpha 1-6 linkages
to give you this
multi-branched structure.
Now, animals don't make starch.
Animals don't make amylopectin.
But animals make
another molecule
called glycogen. Glycogen,
also a sugar polymer,
exactly like amylopectin.
Alpha 1-4 linkages
with the alpha 1-6
to create branch points.
Just like amylopectin,
except glycogen
has even more branches
with a branch every 8
to 12 glucose units.
And so, this is a
very complex structure
for both plants and animals
to quickly store and quickly
release glucose molecules
when they're needed.
Now, this is in contrast
to a glucose polymer
that can be done that has a
very different 3D structure.
So what if we take
starch, and rather
than have these
alpha 1-4 linkages,
but instead replace these
with beta 1-4 linkages?
OK, so now beta linkages.
Looks simple
enough, but changing
the geometry from the alpha to
the beta bond removes the kink.
Now it's much more
of a flat structure.
Turns out this is,
shown on an image here.
So here's a beta
linkage, and suddenly you
have this flat structure.
This is the same polymer
as starch chemically,
but has a different linkage,
the beta 1-4 linkage.
And that polymer with the
beta 1-4 linkage is cellulose.
And cellulose is, of course,
what wood is made out of.
And so wood and potatoes,
cellulose and starch,
exactly the same polymer.
Same number of calories, if you
could access the glucose units.
But the alpha and beta bonds
make them very different.
Obviously, wood and cellulose is
a very good structural polymer
for plants.
We build houses out of it.
We don't build houses
out of potatoes,
but we eat a lot of potatoes.
So equally good molecule
for plants to store lots
of food for energy.
Turns out wood is a great
source of energy too.
You just need to
have an enzyme that
can break the beta 1-4 bond.
Termites have symbiotic microbes
that allow them to do this,
and this is why termites can eat
wood, a lot of energy tied up
in wood.
Now, we lack the time to go
into the details about how
this relates to other
structural carbohydrates.
But in general,
structural carbohydrate or
carbohydrate-like molecules
form polymers of sugar
or related molecules, also
with these beta linkages.
And a good example is
chitin, so the material
in the insect
shells, is basically
a sugar-like molecule
that's a polymer
with a beta linkage in it.
Same thing with cartilage
in humans and animals.
And you can look up
the details of what
these things look like, of
course, if you're interested.
Chitin and cartilage aren't
made of true polysaccharide
polymers, but they're very
related to polysaccharides.
And they really
illustrate how nature
can take carbohydrate
chemistry and repurpose
it to basically act
as an energy source,
but also build all kinds
of structural molecules
that are really
useful in biology.
All right, now I
want to go back to,
here's ways that one can
store and use carbohydrates
in interesting ways.
But now I want to come back
to them as energy sources,
and assuming you can
access the glucose
and whatever polymer
it's present in, how can
you actually metabolize
it to provide energy
in a way that sustains life?
And this means
we're going to turn
to another topic, a
topic that's typically
referred to as bioenergetics.
Bioenergetics, which is
really the discussion
of how energy is transduced
in biological systems.
I'm going to introduce
this topic today,
we're going to revisit
it throughout the course.
But it's really important
to ask this question.
We really want to
consider, what do we mean
when we say biological energy?
What is biological energy?
Well, someone probably made
you memorize in high school,
and often you were
thinking, oh, it's just ATP.
And certainly, ATP,
adenosine triphosphate,
is a very important molecule for
biological energy transduction.
But I want to actually explore
why ATP is actually useful.
And if ATP is energy, why don't
we just eat all kinds of ATP?
I can say for a fact that
absolutely none of you
had ATP today for breakfast.
No one sells ATP as
an energy booster.
And so if ATP is such
a great energy source,
why don't we just eat it?
And to really understand
ATP, how it works,
what biological
energy really is,
we really need to revisit
some very basic topics
in thermodynamics.
Now, thermodynamics strikes
fear into the hearts of students
everywhere.
You can get details of
thermodynamics and the theory
around these things
in other courses.
That's not really what
we're going to try
to accomplish here in 705.
Our goal here is really
a practical understanding
of how thermodynamics applies
to biology and metabolism.
And we need to go into
this, because it's
key to understanding
why we store energy,
go through all this
trouble to store energy
as these carbohydrate
polymers to begin with.
Why we eat potatoes and
not ATP, as well as why ATP
is actually useful to cells.
And so let's take a step
back and just think about it.
Let's think about wood.
I just told you, wood is a
polymer of glucose molecules
with beta 1-4 linkages.
How can we, forget as
organisms, as cells.
But how can you release
energy from wood,
to do other kinds of work?
Well, we can burn it.
And so what's the
chemistry of burning wood?
Well, it's a
carbohydrate polymer.
So it has this CnH2n formula.
If we combine that
carbohydrate with oxygen,
it releases CO2 and water,
plus some light, plus heat.
This light and heat
is energy, because we
can use it to do work.
Boil water, turn a
turbine, make electricity.
Whatever.
Warm ourselves by the fire.
Use the light to do
some other things.
And so this burning of wood is
certainly release of energy.
Now, we lack the enzymes to
do this reaction in wood,
because we can't break
that beta 1-4 linkage.
But we certainly can break that
alpha 1-4 linkage in starch
from potatoes.
And we use the
exact same chemistry
to burn that glucose
and release energy.
Except the difference
is that if I burn wood,
I do this all in one step.
But life is a much better
engineer than that.
It basically, rather
than releasing
all of that energy in
one step, it really
releases it stepwise
in a manner that's
actually useful to cells.
But it's exactly the
same release of energy.
And so what life
is, or extracting
biological energy
is, is it's really
the ability to do stepwise
oxidation of glucose
or other carbon.
I'll write glucose for now.
To get energy.
So we burn wood, that's
favorable, it releases energy.
If we do stepwise
oxidation, we also
can release energy as well.
Same reaction, also
releases energy.
How much energy do
we get from releasing
us burning glucose, as you
do and burning it in a fire?
Well, it has to be exactly
the same amount, because it's
exactly the same reaction.
So we burn wood, we
get light and heat.
Cells burn glucose, it
releases the exact same amount
of energy.
It just does so in a way
that allows the cells to do
biologically useful things.
What are those?
Well, it could be heat.
All of us maintain temperature.
So heat is a
conversion of energy
that of course, is
useful to biology.
But it can do other things, too.
It can allow cells to move.
It can allow them
to do any reaction
to fight that entropy
that allows life to exist.
And so all things,
including ourselves,
have to follow the same
laws of thermodynamics.
Life is not special
in that regard.
And so burning
wood is favorable,
because it increases the
entropy of the universe.
You're breaking up this polymer
into a bunch of monomers.
That's going to be spontaneous.
That is in accordance with the
second law of thermodynamics.
True if cells burn it as well.
But remember, the
second law says
that net entropy of the
universe must always increase.
And so if we're going
to do something that's
not energetically favorable,
like build a glucose polymer,
we obviously have to
put energy into it.
And to do so, the
energy that's released
must be greater than the
energy that we actually store.
And so this is actually a really
key point, because anything
that we do that requires
energy input for a cell
to carry out that process
requires a source of energy
release somewhere else that is
equivalent or greater than what
is actually put in.
And so cells need
energy, because they
do lots of thermodynamically
unfavorable things,
fighting that entropy
of the universe.
And all of those processes must
come from the release of energy
elsewhere, like the
burning of carbohydrate.
And so that constant
energy input
is at the very
highest level, why
we need to do constant
metabolism in order to maintain
order and survive as organisms.
Now this, of course,
comes from things
like burning of carbohydrate.
But of course, that carbohydrate
has to come from somewhere.
And so ultimately, you have
to have an external source.
That external source
is of course, the sun.
Photosynthetic organisms can
use light energy from the sun
to do exactly the same things.
Build those excess
polymers, and that's
why we as animals
or anything that
eats other animals
as a way to live
is ultimately
depending on eating
photosynthetic
organisms, because
photosynthetic organisms
do this by harvesting
energy of the sun.
Now that's all very high level.
But I want to come back to
the specifics of metabolism,
ultimately, and understand those
as how they relate to enzymes'
reactions and pathways.
That is, how do you get that
complex series of reactions
that make life
possible, and ultimately
still be guided by these
exact same principles?
In other words, how do we couple
the energy releasing reactions,
like burning glucose,
in a way that
obeys the laws of thermodynamics
and operates under biologically
acceptable conditions in
order to do things that
are biologically unfavorable.
That's really what
bioenergetics is.
And so the next thing we
want to consider then,
if we want to understand
this, is really,
let's ask the question.
What determines if a
specific reaction occurs?
That is, what determines if
something like burning wood
actually spontaneously happens?
If you light wood on
fire, it will burn.
It does so every
single time, everyone
has had that experience.
But no one has ever seen
CO2 and water spontaneously
come together and form a tree.
That doesn't happen.
So what determines
whether you burn wood
and that is
favorable, versus why
it is that CO2 and water don't
come together and spontaneously
form a tree?
Do not think that this is
determined entirely by enzymes.
Enzymes are catalysts.
Enzymes are the spark that makes
the burning of wood possible.
But remember, enzymes cannot
change thermodynamics.
Enzymes only change the rate
at which a reaction happens.
It does not change
the equilibrium.
That tree wants to, if given the
catalyst, form CO2 and water.
That reaction is
spontaneous because it
is thermodynamically favorable.
That tree will not
take CO2 and water
and spontaneously reform a tree.
And there's no amount
of enzyme that will
make that happen all by itself.
And so remember that.
If you have any reaction
between A and B,
there is some
equilibrium, as defined
by the chemical
properties of A and B,
such that the equilibrium lies
far to one side or the other.
And that equilibrium is
determined by thermodynamics.
It is not determined by enzymes.
I don't care how
much enzyme I add.
If the equilibrium lies
towards A as I draw it,
I can add all the enzyme I want,
and I can never create more B.
And so, this is super
important, and is actually
a point that is gotten
wrong by lots of biologists.
They think, oh, this
enzyme is expressed.
Therefore, this pathway
must be happening,
or this reaction must
be happening faster.
You need an enzyme to
catalyze a reaction.
So a reaction may
not occur, your wood
may not burn unless you
give it a spark, a catalyst
to actually make it happen.
But you cannot add a catalyst
to fight thermodynamics.
You cannot take that CO2
and water and turn it back
into a tree.
And the same thing is true.
You can add all the enzyme
in the world you want,
and all it will do is help A
and B establish the equilibrium
that is defined by
the thermodynamics
of the relationship
between A and B.
Now, what determines
the equilibrium
between any two species?
That's a topic for another
class, why a species is favored
to be one side or another.
However, a useful tool to think
about this in biochemistry
and quantify this for
any pair of reactions
is something you've probably
learned about before.
It's something called
the Gibbs free energy.
Gibbs free energy, or delta G.
Delta G is related
to the way we'll talk
about the equilibrium constant.
And it's basically
a term that we
can use to specify if a
reaction is favorable or not.
And so hopefully you learned
in an introductory class
that if delta G is less than
0, our reaction is spontaneous.
If delta G equals 0, our
reaction is that equilibrium.
If delta G is greater
than 0, our reaction
is not spontaneous.
All right, if we
take our log and ask,
what is delta G to turn that
log into CO2 plus water,
it is less than 0, because
it is very spontaneous.
We take a pile of
ashes and ask what
delta G is to recreate the log.
It's greater than 0, because
it ain't going to happen.
And if it's at some equilibrium,
delta G is equal to 0.
Now, delta G depends
entirely on conditions,
as we will see in a minute.
And because of that,
this means that there
can be conditions where
absolutely any reaction can
be favorable if the
conditions are right.
And we'll see that this becomes
very relevant to understand
how metabolism works.
And so let's go back
and just now consider
some generic reaction, A and B.
So at equilibrium, what happens?
So at equilibrium,
the concentration of A
and the concentration
of B are not changing.
Delta G equals 0.
These two things
are at equilibrium,
whatever that equilibrium is.
A and B are not changing
in concentration.
Now if I come and I add more A
to this side of the equation,
what does that mean?
Well, you know from Le
Chatelier's principle
that that's going
to favor production
of B. We have shifted things
now out of equilibrium.
So if I add A, that
leads the production of B
to re-establish
this equilibrium.
That means that delta G
from A to B is less than 0
until I've reestablished
equilibrium,
and now delta G is
back to 0 again.
Now, what happens if I add B?
Well, if I add B, now I'm
going to produce some A. So
add B. That leads
the production of A,
until I reestablish
that equilibrium.
So delta G, in that
case, to go from B
back to A. The reverse
reaction is less than 0.
Or I could also say that
delta G, to go to A to B
here, because that's
not going to happen.
I just added more
B. I'm not going
to suddenly create
more B from A.
So here now, delta
G is greater than 0.
Now note when I did
this, I don't actually
have to specify how much A
or how much B I've added.
The equilibrium depends
on the ratio of B to A.
Not the absolute concentration
of either species.
And so having a way to think
about this equilibrium,
it turns out, is also useful
for biological systems
to divine some delta G
that is helpful to relate
to this equilibrium constant.
And that is this concept
of delta G 0 prime.
A standard free energy,
which for biological systems,
relates to the equilibrium
constant at 25 degrees,
or the pH of 7 and 1 atmosphere.
Pretty typical
biological conditions.
And this here is
basically related
to the equilibrium constant.
And we can calculate
the actual delta G
by the following formula.
Delta G equals delta
G 0 prime plus RT
times the log of the
products over the reactant.
So this would be drawn
for the reaction A to B.
So the reaction
A to B is related
to delta G 0 prime, which is
related to the equilibrium
constant.
I'll tell you how in the second.
Plus R is the gas constant, T
is the temperature in Kelvin
times the natural log of
the ratio of products,
B over reactants, A. This
tells you whether or not
at specific
concentrations of B and A,
that is a specific
ratio of B and A,
whether it is favorable
to go from A to B, delta G
less than 0, or whether it is
favorable to go from B to A,
delta G greater than 0.
And so this should begin to make
it clear that whether or not
a specific reaction
occurs is affected
by the actual
conditions present.
And you can calculate that
based on this relationship.
And so if I specify
concentrations of A and B,
as well as delta
G 0 prime, I can
know, at those concentrations,
which direction of the reaction
is favored.
Now of course, my drawing A
to B is entirely arbitrary.
I could equally draw
it B to A. And if I
did that, so this is delta
G 0 prime, A to B, all I do
is flip the signs.
So delta G equals
delta G 0 prime.
The negative of A to B is equal
to the positive of delta G 0
prime from B to A, because
the direction is arbitrary.
Plus RT log in this case.
Now I have A is my product,
and B is my reactant.
If I just flip the
sign, flip that ratio,
it's just going to change
the sign of my product
and give me exactly the same
result with the opposite sign,
which makes sense.
What's favorable
in one direction
is not favorable in the other
direction, and vice versa.
Now, I can also set
delta G equals 0.
That's equilibrium.
If I do that, then delta G
0 prime equals negative RT.
So this would be for A to
B. I'll use the top example.
So delta G equals 0.
Then I have delta G 0 prime
equals RT times log B over A.
So if I know two things
are at equilibrium,
I can calculate delta G 0 prime,
and know what the equilibrium
constant is.
And so it follows from this
then that if delta G 0 prime
is negative, that means B is
favored over A at equilibrium.
And if delta G 0
prime is positive,
that means A is favored
over B at equilibrium.
And so delta G 0 prime
really is a convenient way
to look at a reaction, and know
which direction the equilibrium
lies.
So A and B, delta G
0 prime is negative,
equilibrium lies to B. Between
A and B, if delta G 0 prime
is positive, the
equilibrium lies towards A.
But the key concept is that
for any specific reaction,
any specific conditions of
A and B, whether or not A
is converted to B will be
defined by the equilibrium
constant.
But it will also be
defined about what delta
is under those conditions.
So to be clear, delta G
will depend on conditions,
because I'll write
it again, delta G
equals delta G 0 prime plus RT
times the log for the reaction,
A goes to B. So
products over reactants.
And so whether or not
A is converted to B
will be a property of
the equilibrium constant,
plus the concentration of B
and the concentration of A,
that ratio of concentrations
at the conditions present.
And if in that calculation,
delta G is less than 0,
that reaction is spontaneous.
If delta G is greater
than 0, that reaction
is not spontaneous.
Or to put it another way,
if delta G is less than 0
under those conditions,
energy is released.
Or if delta G is greater
than 0, that reaction
will not occur
without energy input.
If I burn wood,
energy is released.
But there's no way
I can reassemble
that log without some
kind of energy input.
And really getting
this concept is
central to understanding
metabolism, as well as
what biological energy means.
And hopefully, what
is now apparent,
based on what I just said, is
that what really determines
delta G is two things.
Of course it's the
equilibrium constant.
But in essence, delta
G for any reaction
is proportional to the
ratio of the reactants
over the products.
And that I can come
up, at least in theory,
with any relationship, any
ratio of reactants to products
to make this favorable.
At some tiny, tiny
concentration,
if I have nothing
but CO2 and water,
and infinite time and infinite
catalysis, a tiny bit of wood
could spontaneously form.
And so life really
creates the conditions
that allow that, and select for
that to happen, and of course,
add energy input so it
can actually happen more.
And so this should
be very clear to you
that absolutely no
reaction is irreversible.
I don't care what
your textbook says.
Lots of sources will discuss
irreversible reactions.
I'll talk about irreversible
reactions later in the course.
But what we mean when we say the
word irreversible reaction is
these are under
conditions that are
found in cells and in nature.
And I stress this
because if we want
to understand the energetics
for how pathways work,
we have to appreciate that
life can create conditions
to do unfavorable things,
because that's the only way
that pathways can work.
All right, what what
do I mean by that?
Well, suppose again, we'll
come back to our reaction.
A goes to B. Suppose I need
to build a pathway where
I need to convert A to
B, because B is actually
useful for some purpose
that I need to do in a cell.
However, what if
this is at least
by equilibrium, unfavorable?
What if the equilibrium
lies towards A?
That means delta G 0 prime is
positive, is greater than 0,
for A to B.
What does that mean?
Delta G 0 prime greater than
0, for the reaction A to B?
That means the equilibrium
lies towards A.
And so there is no
amount of enzyme
I can add that will
allow me to net convert A
to B, because the equilibrium
lies far towards A.
However, whether or not a cell
is able to build a pathway,
where it converts A to
B depends on delta G,
not the equilibrium constant
for that specific reaction.
So how can I turn A into B?
Well, I could turn A into B if I
keep the concentration of B low
enough that delta G, not
delta G 0 prime, that's
the equilibrium
constant, but delta G
favors A to B conversion?
That is, delta G for
A to B is less than 0.
How can I do that?
Well, remember delta G equals
delta G 0 prime plus RT
log of B over A. So this term
is positive, because I told you,
the equilibrium
lies towards A. So I
need a concentration,
a ratio of B to A,
such that B is low enough that
this term is more negative
than that term is positive.
And if that's the case,
delta G will be less than 0,
and I can net move that forward.
So how can I do that?
How can I keep the
concentration of B low?
Well, I can build a
pathway that consumes
B in a way to keep it low,
which favors A to B conversion.
In other words, I can build a
pathway, A goes to B goes to C.
So even here, where
delta G 0 prime
is greater than 0, if delta G
0 prime for this reaction, B
to A, is much less than 0,
such that equilibriums strongly
favor C, that means my
unfavorable equilibrium here
can be overcome by the very
favorable equilibrium of B
to C. In essence, I can use
B to C to pull A to B, such
that it actually happens.
Produce this intermediate that's
useful on the path to making C.
This strategy is used in
lots of metabolic pathways.
And it's useful to
generate lots of chemically
useful intermediates.
Now note that this only will
work if conversion of A to C
is favorable.
That is, if delta G 0
prime is less than 0.
I can only pull this reaction if
delta G 0 prime is less than 0.
That is, if equilibrium
favors A to C,
I can build a pathway this way
to do something unfavorable
on the way to making C.
This brings up
another key point,
in that everything
that we discuss,
relationship between
any two metabolites
in any single
reaction, also must
be true for entire pathways.
So I have a three-step
pathway from A
to C. Whether I turn
A into C in one step,
or turn A into C
in multiple steps,
the free energy is
exactly the same.
If I burn wood by
lighting it on fire,
it releases the same
amount of energy
than if a termite
has an enzyme that
breaks that beta 1-4
linkage in the wood,
and can burn that glucose
stepwise through metabolism,
the exact same amount
of energy is released.
Glucose on one side, CO2
and water on the other side,
exactly the same
amount of energy
released, whether I
do it in one step,
or I do it in multiple steps.
The equilibrium constant between
those has to be the same,
and the delta G has to be
the same between all of it.
And so it should become
apparent, then, that A to C
has to be favorable if I'm going
to use this trick of keeping
product low in order to pull an
otherwise unfavorable reaction
forward.
In other words,
there's no way for me
to keep B low and net convert
A to B all on its own.
That will not work.
And it's these unfavorable
reactions that ultimately
then require energy input.
And this is where ATP now starts
becoming useful for cells.
OK, so now I want
to talk a little bit
about how ATP provides
energy that allows otherwise
unfavorable reactions to occur.
And ATP is useful
because delta G
applies to sets of
reactions in the same way it
applies to single reactions.
That is, it applies
to whole systems.
All reactions are a
series of reactions,
whether they happen alone
or coupled together.
All have to follow
the same rules.
So now let's make our
reaction more complicated.
Let's say A plus B goes to C
plus D, where this is really
two reactions coupled together.
A being turned into C,
and B being turned into D.
All right, so will
this reaction happen?
Can I turn A plus
B into C plus D?
Well, how do I know?
Well, it's going to be,
got to calculate delta G.
And so it's going to be delta
G 0 prime for A going to C,
plus delta G 0 prime
for B going to D.
So those will relate to
what's the equilibrium
constant, the equilibrium
relationship between A and C
and B and D. If
it's less than 0,
equilibrium will
favor to the right.
If it's greater
than 0, equilibrium
will favor to the left
of A and C and B and D.
Add them together, that gives
me my overall delta G 0 prime
for those two reactions.
Plus RT times the
log of the products.
So that's C and D over A and
B. Products over the reactants.
So if I take an unfavorable
reaction-- say, A to C,
if delta G 0 prime is greater
than 0, so it would favor A,
and I couple it to
another reaction, B
to D that's very favorable,
because I add these two
terms together.
I can now take something
where the equilibrium
would be unfavorable,
and make it favorable.
However, whether or not
this actually happens still
depends on this ratio of
products to reactants.
So it still depends on
the ratio of C to A,
and D to B in our
hypothetical thing here.
So to know if a specific
reaction will actually occur,
we have to take into account
both the sum of the delta G
primes related to the
equilibrium constant,
and the actual ratios
that are present in cells.
And so the net
effect is that I can
couple more favorable
reactions to make otherwise
unfavorable reactions
now become favorable.
That is, have energy input.
But it still depends
on conditions.
And so let's think a little
bit about the polymer synthesis
that we learned from
Professor Yaffe.
And so in that process,
what did we do?
We made several polymers, and
you learned about the chemistry
to do this.
We made DNA, we made
RNA, and we made protein.
These are polymers
of nucleic acids.
Protein is a polymer
of amino acids.
All of these fight
entropy, right?
We're building polymers,
not breaking them down.
And all of them were
synthesized using
reactions that hydrolyzed ATP.
In fact, those
reactions actually
hydrolyzed ATP in
the following way.
And every single one of those
cases, if you look back,
what you will see
is that they all
had steps where ATP
was taken to AMP
plus 2 inorganic phosphates.
This reaction is very favorable.
In fact, it's two reactions.
It's really ATP goes to
AMP plus pyrophosphate.
And then that pyrophosphate
goes to 2 inorganic phosphates.
It turns out that delta
G 0 prime is less than 0
for both of these reactions.
That means the equilibrium lies
towards AMP plus pyrophosphate.
And here, the equilibrium lies
towards 2 inorganic phosphates.
And so there's actually two
tricks here by metabolism.
One is, it's two very
favorable reactions
that we're coupled to do
something unfavorable,
build a polymer.
And use the trick of
keeping pyrophosphate low
by coupling it to a downstream,
very favorable reaction, which
even further pulls
this reaction, and is
why ATP hydrolysis here
becomes so useful as a way
to build these polymers.
Let's just go quickly
and add a few numbers
to show exactly what I mean
by how ATP hydrolysis can
be useful in this setting.
And so, let's do something
a little simpler.
Let's go to ATP plus ADP
plus to inorganic phosphate.
So let's give this some
numbers, delta G 0 prime
in this case is equal to
negative 7.5 kcals per mole.
All right, what does this mean?
Delta G 0 prime is related
to the equilibrium constant.
It's less than 0, which
means the equilibrium lies
towards ADP plus phosphate.
Now let's see how
this actually helps
by considering what the
first step in glucose
metabolism by cells is.
So the first step cells
do in glucose metabolism
is add an inorganic
phosphate group to glucose.
So it's this reaction,
glucose plus inorganic
phosphate goes to
glucose phosphate.
Just a quick note on shorthand
that I will use in this course.
So PI, of course, is
inorganic phosphate.
That is this PO43 minus group.
When it forms a
phosphodiester bond,
like to an alcohol and one
of the glucose molecules,
I'll draw this in
a future lecture.
I'll oftentimes
indicate it by putting
a circle around the phosphate.
And so adding this
phosphate to glucose
is a step that traps
that glucose in cells.
For now, let's just
consider this reaction.
And so delta G 0
prime of this reaction
is positive 3.3 kcals per mole.
What does that mean?
Delta G 0 prime relates to
the equilibrium constant.
It says the equilibrium
constant lies here to the left,
to the glucose plus
phosphate side.
So if we want to net trap
glucose phosphate in cells,
well, it's not going to
happen spontaneously.
You need some kind
of energy input.
That can come from ATP.
And so if we couple those
two reactions as follows.
So we now have glucose plus
ATP goes to glucose phosphate
plus ADP.
Now let's draw this out.
Will this happen?
So we can calculate delta G.
Delta G equals delta G 0 prime.
So there's two reactions
happening here,
glucose to glucose
phosphate, and ATP to ADP.
We know what delta G 0 prime
is by adding those together.
So it's 3.3 plus negative 7.5.
That equals negative 4.2.
What does that tell us?
That says, now we've
created conditions
where the equilibrium constant
lies towards the right,
towards the glucose
phosphate plus ADP side.
But how much of this
occurs or whether it occurs
isn't just the property
the equilibrium constant.
It's also how much is there.
And so that's RT times
the log of the products,
glucose phosphate.
And ADP over glucose.
And ATP.
And so, if this term
is less than 4.2--
that is, if the ratio of glucose
phosphate to glucose and ADP
to ATP in this term ends up
being less than positive 4.2,
this reaction is spontaneous.
It is favored.
Lots of conditions
where that would
be the case, although if
this term is 4.2 or greater,
now it will no longer occur.
How much ATP is needed?
Well, it's hard to answer this
question in absolute terms,
because if there's
a lot of ADP around,
you need a lot more ATP
for the ADP to be useful.
And this is the problem with
equating ATP with energy.
The energy here is in the ratio
of ATP to ADP, or ADP to ATP.
And this is something
that we we'll come back to
in the next lecture,
because in the end,
this is what will determine
if a reaction has happened.
It is not the absolute
concentration of ATP.
It's the fact that ATP
hydrolysis is favorable.
But how favorable
that is depends
on the relevant
concentrations of ATP or ADP.
And relative concentrations
are all that matters
in thermodynamics.
It is not absolute
concentrations.
It is the ATP-ADP ratio
that is the correct way
to think about energy.
And this is true for any
reaction with respect
to energetics.
If an ATP-ADP ratio
exists, such that when
coupled to a reaction,
delta G is less than 0,
then it becomes spontaneous.
And this is how ATP
provides energy.
And we will come back to this
more in the next lecture.
Thank you.